hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and as long time listeners know uh i'm a
physicist theoretical physicist
i have certain other interests
intellectually academically so forth
but i also have you know my personal
hobbies and my
individual enthusiasms i try not
to force my individual enthusiasms on
the mindscape audience
too much sometimes it leaks through we
get the occasional
jazz musician or poker player but mostly
we're talking about academic type things
today one of the times when we're going
to take a little bit of a detour we're
going to be talking about
basketball and the national basketball
association the highest level of
basketball
being played out there but i think this
is a special case if there is one person
you would want to talk to about the idea
of modern basketball
to an audience or with an audience that
was intellectually and analytically
inclined
but not necessarily full of basketball
fans
it would be today's guests daryl mori is
the general manager
of the philadelphia 76ers now
coincidentally the philadelphia 76ers
are the best basketball team in the
world i could
say this very objectively it's not just
because i grew up in philadelphia
watching dr j and moses malone and mo
cheeks and bobby jones and so forth it's
just because it's an objective fact they
don't always win
they're sort of at the top of the heap
when it comes to one's favorite
basketball team if one is just objective
about it
but that's just a coincidence daryl was
the general manager of the houston
rockets for a long time he just came
to philadelphia very recently the
general manager for those of you who
don't know is kind of like the boss
of the basketball team he's the one who
hires the coach
drafts the players makes trades signs
free asian stuff like that the person
who's ultimately responsible
for assembling the basketball team and
what's special about daryl mori is
he more than any other person has been
responsible for
dragging the national basketball
association into the modern
data-centered analytical age in terms of
trying to understand what it means
to build a team to best position
yourself to win games and win
the championships so if it were just me
talking to daryl mori for an hour
without anyone listening in i'd be very
tempted to geek out about
basketball or 76ers minutiae you know
should we try to land a stretch for or
is it more important to prioritize
perimeter creation
things like this who are you targeting
in the trade market but
i put that aside i put aside my impulses
to do that for the greater good
of the mindscape audience and instead
what we're talking about today is
the theory of being a general manager
okay and i think that whether or not you
care at all about basketball this is an
idea that has
much broader application there's no
basketball knowledge or interest
required but
what we'll be talking about is a
combination of science
art and human relations okay if you're a
general manager of a basketball team
you have an extremely quantifiable goal
you want to win games and ultimately win
championships okay you know whether you
have succeeded
or not in ways that are highly
quantifiable as i said
much more clear cut than in many other
areas of human endeavor
and you also have resources abilities
that are very quantifiable you have
players they can score
they do score at a certain rate they can
pass they can rebound they can play
defense etc
then the question becomes how do you
optimize how do you
give in your resources combine them
together there's a salary cap
in the nba so you can only pay your
players so much you can't just outbid
everyone else for the best players in
the league
what are the data that you need to take
into consideration what are the data you
should ignore what are the things you
should not care too much about
how do you both correct for the biases
that human beings
inevitably have but also recognize that
human beings
do have some intuitive knowledge of
things sometimes right there really is
human insight
that needs to be taken into account what
about not just the player's ability to
pass and score but also
their ability to mix right their
personalities do you need a leader do
you want focal players
can you put up with the superstar who's
kind of grumpy stuff like that
okay so to me this kind of much like
poker in some sense
what we have here is a toy model what we
have here
is a paradigm for all sorts of
optimization problems that we face in
the everyday world
one where the answers ultimately are
very clear-cut whether you have
succeeded or not
daryl mori is someone who succeeded a
great deal over his years
as a general manager in houston they
compiled the second best overall record
in the nba second only to the san
antonio spurs
congratulations to them uh and currently
as i
record this intro the sixers are the
first place team in the eastern
conference of the nba so we'll see how
that goes you know
who knows what happens as the future
trundles on uh
injuries all sorts of crazy things can
happen in a sport like this you don't
need to know anything about basketball
or the sixers or the current state of
the nba
we will mention joel embiid center for
the philadelphia 76ers currently an mvp
candidate
also ben simmons point guard for the
sixers another all-star
and doc rivers of course who coaches the
76ers but you don't need to know any of
that stuff
the concepts we're talking about are
much more general and in the end
just in case you want a little bit of
physics in your life we talk about dark
matter
i think that one of the reasons why
daryl took time out of his busy schedule
to be on the mindscape podcast is
because he wanted to talk about
dark matter he was skeptical that dark
matter really exists i gave him my sales
pitch for why it does
we'll see whether or not that convinced
him whether it convinces you
let's go
daryl mori welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me on sean
appreciate it
uh so this is unusual we'd like to have
some people on the podcast
who are not phds and professors and
things so this is a wonderful addition
to that tradition but not many of our
many of our
audience members will not be the rabid
philadelphia 76ers fan
that i am growing up you know worshiping
julius irving and so
forth so why don't we start very very
basic uh
what do you do what is the day in the
life of a general manager
like are you just on the phone all the
time talking about trades with other
general managers or what is the
day-to-day
well it's like it's like most things as
you move higher up you just become more
of a tax on the system
you know that's how i look at it but
yeah i
i mean i started out as a computer
science programmer
way back when and and got into
basketball in 2002
oh i always played basketball but i got
into the boston celtics
in the nba in 2002. sorry to hear that
and i started off doing data
and coding and uh you know now i get to
do very little of that except you know
run the teams that do that uh and yeah
as i go on more of my time is on the
phone
and meeting you know players and coaches
and owners and
fans and business people and you know as
as you get higher up you end up just
talking more uh it's like
yeah podcast like being a department
chair or president of university you
know who have to do you presumably you
don't have to do fundraising but there
is fan outreach i presume
yeah in fact to the point where i'm sure
you might be like this sean where you
you just i when i get to do some stuff
where i'm
digging into data and solving a problem
i get so excited
like oh yeah and then my my poor staff
is like well just let us do it leave us
alone you know
so i tried to do that because that's how
i would be if i were them
well you know and presumably the
landscape has changed a little bit since
nowadays
people can have a video game where they
play
at being the general manager right so
like everyone is an amateur who's going
to give you advice on your job i'm sure
that's that's the right and and i'd be
you'd be shocked like the amateurs are
very sophisticated i think that's true
in a lot of fields like there's
there's you know just die-hards who know
the team
know the data know everything um
you know there's a rights to ricky
sanchez podcast with
a couple die hards who are very smart uh
there's you know message boards
and every team has a guest on the rights
to ricky sanchez i've appeared on the
podcast before you did yeah
oh wow so you're a pioneer you were
probably so
i was hoping i could be maybe one of the
smarter ones in the podcast but now i've
been
i've been usurped for sure but you and
joelle joelle's been on he's
so joel is shockingly smart it'd be
great to have julio join you
he's like i mean i shouldn't say
shocking that sounds bad but he's
he's like and you know just and he's uh
what polymath is that is that the word
like he's
he's really smart about a lot of things
and and on the court as well obviously
right this is joelle and beat we're
talking about obviously the philadelphia
76ers
star center i mean it is interesting
because some people
uh and i i completely agree that my
impression of joelle is that he's super
duper smart
but you know but he doesn't project that
way right like he doesn't put on
affectation i think that actually minute
bowl was someone who was like that a
previous
philadelphia 76ers center everyone used
to say when they talked to him he
how smart he was i've i've heard that
about minutes
i mean there's some i mean i've known
lots of smart players firsthand like
like shane battier but then
you have like chris bosh is like was a
coder sam dallenberger was like building
his own machines when
before that was a thing i so i mean you
the thing is like if you make it to the
top of your sport whether it be player
or whatever
you usually are pretty good on g like
you usually usually have
pretty good pattern matching to make it
that far so
yeah there's a lot of tall people out
there like some people tell people but
you need more than just that
so so your goal i mean how would you say
that your goal is as the general manager
obviously you want to win
the championship every year but maybe
that's not uh
plausible do you sort of optimize to get
a chance to win a championship or
long-term success and of course there's
always a danger of being fired it's the
real world
how do you think about what your job is
yeah it's exactly the right question
i would say um yeah i'd say
so the first thing you do is it's like
organisms you have to survive
so you're right like um whether it's
right or wrong i would say most people
and i for sure focused on this early in
my career a little less so later which
is nice
try to like just make it to the next
year like to
and and hopefully you can always align
your girls with the organization
but in terms of thinking about
what we're optimizing it's pretty owner
dependent
um you know i've been lucky i've always
had owners who are like just
championship or bus
like that is your goal but even within
that to your point if you just focus on
winning in one year
you'll you'll create all these weird
skus so we
we look over about a three year window
and we're trying to optimize
our championship probability over that
three-year window
um and we use a lot of outside measures
to
we have internal measures and outside
measures we like right now vegas
i think has us like about a six percent
chance to win the title and that sounds
like really small but it turns out to be
pretty high that's
i think that's fifth or sixth in the
league yeah okay
and and you personally uh where do you
put your your chances
yeah we have them internally higher but
that that's true
almost always right so whatever process
you have whatever team you are
if you don't think you have a higher
chance than vegas
uh then that means you're not actually
following any sort of
proprietary process the reality is
though everyone can't be right so
yep you need these outside objective
measures to keep you grounded and so if
you differ
a lot from vegas and vegas has become
pretty sophisticated with how well they
measure things as you know football's
always been the most efficient
basketball has become
very efficient over the last 10 years if
you if you differ in a big way
uh that means you probably need to look
at your own stuff like it's pretty hard
to get a huge edge on
on vegas jen just to give uh the
listeners who are not
basketball fans a feeling for this
there's one little anecdote that i read
that i thought was hilarious
sergey lishok the best ukrainian
basketball player remember his name
yes sergei leshok yeah i think i mean
honestly you probably said it right
we always call them sergey let's shoot
so that's yeah so
the the thing i read was he was drafted
by the memphis grizzlies in 2004
and again for those who don't know you
draft the rights to a player you may or
may not sign them to a contract and then
you can
trade the rights to sign that person to
someone else that's why the rights to
ricky
sanchez podcast has that funny name so
apparently you personally are
uh responsible for trading the rights to
sergey lishuk uh
five different times either training for
him or trading trading him away he's
never played in the nba he's already
retired he never will
yeah just for the audience it's sort of
interesting so the nba draft is this
sort of
weird system that doesn't really exist
many other places
and what it is is that sean you have
been in the nba draft and really
everyone listening at one point male or
female has been
in the nba draft at age 22 the year you
turn 22
you're in the draft and you don't have
to declare
anything you just have to be 22. if you
happen to be selected by a team they
obviously can't force you to play for
the team
you have to come to a contractual
agreement and they're generally
prearranged depending on where you're
picked
and often those players either aren't
good enough so the team never offers a
contract
or the player doesn't want to come which
has happened
in the case of players like sergio yol
who we drafted in houston
and so yeah long story short you you can
hold these
options of players to come and they have
all options always have some sort of
value depending on the variance and the
underlying asset
and they get traded a lot mostly because
a lot of it's because the nba doesn't
understand that there are negative
numbers
in the world no i'm actually serious
yeah
they the and to be fair to the mba this
is a legal thing
apparently too that in a lot of contract
law they don't understand that there are
things called negative assets
so even though a team might be trading a
positive and a negative asset together
to a team such that it's neutral such
that they'll just take it together and
it
and they don't need to send anything
back uh the nba
forces you uh to send something back
and so often these these options become
just
the the word you write such that the
trade is legal
even though yeah even though it doesn't
make any sense yeah
and if i understand correctly a negative
asset isn't just a basketball player who
is so bad they make you lose it's that
maybe you're
you're contracted to pay them more than
they're worth 100
right yeah exactly right and to your
point on
everyone being gm everyone gets this now
because 2k
for example is like i think one of the
top 10 most popular games in the world
and no one actually plays it no one
plays the game the game play
is how the game was created but now it's
like more than half of the time spent on
it
is just playing gm and simulating the
games and not actually playing them
um so yeah everyone everyone's a gm
and which is cool i mean i think it's
just part of being
a fan of a team now yeah absolutely all
right so
moving into a little bit more of the
nitty-gritty i mean the thing one has to
talk about when you have daryl morey on
the podcast is
when you're evaluating players there has
been a seismic shift over the years
from listening to the wise counsel
of scouts who have been looking at these
players and developing their personal
opinions
to a more statistical data-based
approach and you have a lot to do with
that i mean
what's your big picture overview of
where that came from and how it's going
yeah and so i think my job is just it's
really the same as red auerbach who's a
famous gm for the celtics for many years
is you know help your team win and make
good decisions on your three levers
draft trade and free agency
and how do you and so my job is the
decision-making job
more than anything else and how do you
create a consistent edge there and it's
by studying decision science and so if
you study
decision science you'll see there's been
a lot of research over the last 30 years
especially
on you know how uh you know
behavioral economics is a big one on all
the different cognitive biases
anchoring endowment effect all those
things
then there's a huge set of research on
combining data
uh and human judgment uh to make a
decision so
we try to employ all those methods
to create an edge and honestly what
we're trying to generate is a three to
five percent edge
which again doesn't sound like a lot but
over time compounds basically
and so that and so we use a lot of data
and
with scouts for example we you
we you know we look at it as what is a
scout's experience it's it's a very good
set of data built up over 20 30 years of
players and the patterns of the players
that succeed that are all in their head
and humans are actually really good at
this they're really good at finding
patterns
they're often very too good at finding
patterns and that's often where data
comes in so
data like grounds you just like i said
look at vegas
and compare it to your own models at all
times if a scout
or myself is very far afield from the
general consensus
could be right but you want to like ask
the questions why do you think he's not
much better and then dig
into each thing so data like actually
forces you to ask the questions
to make your decisions more precise
essentially so that's
i don't know if that's a summary that
helps hopefully yeah it does i mean
it raises the question do you do
longitudinal analysis of the success of
scouts like are some scouts
really really good at finding the
diamonds in the rough so we do
it's tricky though because you have an
observer effect which i
would not not the physics observer
effect this is the
this is the human observer effect which
is
you know as you as you measure people
they definitely change their behavior so
i i tend to be
a little more of a hands-off i don't try
and
and you use the right word longitudinal
look over a very long period
of who's successful and who isn't the
problem is we have a big windowing
problem so by the time
you might have a sense that someone's
three percent better
or two percent worse you know it's
it takes like 12 years like it's just
it's tough so
a lot of it you have to use your own
human intuition of who you think
are maybe better or worse scouts better
or worse decision makers it's it's
i wish it was all science it's not it's
art and science like most things
that's kind of fun though if you have 30
minutes free you never have to worry
about a break-in at your home
ever again that's how quick and easy it
is to set up a security system from
simplisafe
it's the kind of thing that's so easy to
do you can do it during a netflix binge
watching a game
or listening to a certain podcast i have
a simply safe system myself and look i'm
a theoretical physicist
setting up electronic systems is
actually not close to my core competency
but i had no trouble putting together
the simplisafe system you can choose
exactly the sensors you need video
cameras motion detectors window sensors
etc
and you can program those motion
detectors to not detect your pets
which is crucially important here at
mindscape world headquarters it's easy
to assume that everyone in your house
already feels safe but they might not
and it's worthwhile to talk about it
simply safe is a small easy step to make
sure everyone feels safe at your home
so go to simplysafe.com mindscape today
to customize your system and get a free
security camera
you also get a 60-day risk-free trial so
there's nothing to lose that's
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e dot com slash
mindscape
and when it just comes to the players i
mean there's been not only an
increased understanding that the
statistics are useful but the kinds of
statistics that we have
right i mean we used to keep track of
how many points how many rebounds how
many assists a player would have
these days i mean again you're the
expert i'll let you say it but
we are uh we collect an enormous amount
of data
not only at all different levels but in
the arena there's cameras keeping track
of everything how many
what's the average speed what's probably
what the variance of the speed of a
player on the court is how many miles
they go the whole bit
yeah to your point like in a lot of
fields now there's no
there's no lack of data it's really you
have more of a lack of an imagination or
how to analyze the data but so we have
data from the mba all the way down to
like
second third division germany that kind
of a level
and and college and some high school
of every play that's happening around
the world
right and to your point in the mba we
have and
and in the d league and then probably
coming to college soon or
to a few arenas in college already 25
times a second
in three dimensions the ball and all
players on the
floor so you're really only limited by
your imagination if you want to know was
that shot open you can
you can look that up and so yeah we
spent
so the problem isn't the data the
there's two ways
we're trying to create an edge so
there's two ways to create an edge you
have to have unique data
and that's hard to come by although we
have some
and then or you have better analysts and
that's also a hard one to
have a consistent advantage in over time
now we used to have a huge advantage
in houston and my belief and i think
sort of borne out
by the fact we never had a losing season
and had the second most wins
over the over the years that that a lot
of those edges have eroded
and now it's like chasing it's it's it's
similar to
you know if you were a physicist in 1880
there's probably a lot of stuff to do
and uh there still is a lot of stuff to
do but it's harder it takes longer to
get to the
unique nuggets now in physics i would
guess
than it did in 1880 when we didn't know
relativity and a whole bunch of other
stuff
so yeah so just to put it in context
when you became
the gm of the rockets in houston uh not
that many teams were devoted to this
idea
of collecting all the data you can
analyzing it and so
you got to be out in front a little bit
there and by now everyone else has
caught up more or less
yeah absolutely like in 2006 it was
of course people knew but it was
somewhat
uh novel that shooting three pointers
and getting three points is better than
shooting twos and getting twos like
that it seems pretty straightforward
that you want to take a shot that's
worth 50
more than the other one but it turned
out not to be in fact
teams were actively avoiding those shots
mostly because of the human
how that it was introduced it was
introduced to the game
after a lot of the models on how to win
with two-pointers came out
and because it was introduced late
everyone thought it was a gimmick and to
be avoided and all the people who were
coaches and players at the time
were like ah that's a stupid gimmick but
they didn't realize the power of it at
the time and
it took like 25 30 years before people
started using it correctly
well that that's absolutely true and
it's a weird number 25 or 30 years is a
long
time and so to be fair sure three-point
shot is worth 50
more but you miss it more often and
there's also like these confounding
things that people believed i think it
turned out not to be true but they
believed that
your team was less likely to get the
rebound back uh
after a three-pointer so you kind of you
kind of had to dig into it yeah
correct there was a lot of reasonable
objections that could have been true it
just
so happened that none of them were so
yeah you could
shoot them at a low enough percentage
such that it's not worth it that turned
out not it turns out people shoot eight
foot shots at about the same
percentage or within a few percentage
points of what they shoot
25 foot shots so that's a
counter-intuitive thing like you
wouldn't
know that until you actually played i
think it's intuitive to your point that
people thought yeah you'd get longer
rebounds that the other team might get
and turn into transition
that turned out not to be true now of
course those happen but they're just
anecdotal they're very small relative to
the whole set people thought maybe
uh an open two-pointer would be better
than a
fairly challenged three-pointer that
also turned out to not be true
so just as you keep diving in it just
turns out that
50 more is such a huge edge that
uh that that it was worth it's worth
taking under most
most conditions and you know people
don't love that but i mean
the reality is that the three-pointer if
it was if we were an esport
the three-pointer would have been nerfed
a while ago i mean
they they would have changed it to be
worth less it would have been worth two
and a half
or something like that well and also
let's admit that there is
uh an almost a macho component right uh
you know a lot of people
in and analyzing the sport were
ex-players themselves and there's
a feeling that if you bully your way
down under the basket and slam dunk on
someone you've achieved more
than if you've just lofted a shot from
35 feet away
that's very insightful yeah they're
they're i mean any sport
with men and that's true i mean there's
a competitiveness and aggressiveness
that often gives you an edge
but that edge can also be your weakness
and it's absolutely true that like
i always talk about this there are ways
that fans and coaches and gm's
are comfortable with losing and there
are ways that they're uncomfortable with
losing
so ways that people are very
uncomfortable are losing like in
football as if
if they can just run it down the middle
every time get four yards
and do that every time and win that's an
uncomfortable way to lose but
if a team you know makes a lot of long
passes and they seem unlikely
and do then they're fine with it usually
similar in basketball
if if on a given night you take a bunch
of open
18-footers and happen to miss them and
lose they're like ah
wasn't your night but if if the other
team like
posts you up and you know makes you look
bad and
throws it one inch from the hoop now
now it's like our to your point it's a
very insightful one now it's like our
our manhood is being challenged and
that's not a good way to lose
and it's i i think in any sport
analyze the ways that you're allowed to
lose and not allowed to lose and you
learn a lot about the culture
of the sport so other than
shooting for three points is even better
than shooting for two points
is there anything that we've learned
from this you know ultra high resolution
25 frames a second data about ball
movement and things like that that is
just
that just smacked you in the head you
said oh my goodness that's
counter-intuitive but now that
we think of it oh my goodness yeah
there's a lot on rebounding
so to your point a lot of the analysis
on
um on rebounding in terms of you know
there isn't more long rebounds that
that's a big one
um you know there's a lot on that
there's a trade-off between obviously
basketball is one of the coolest most
dynamic sports everyone plays offense on
defense and it goes back and forth very
rapidly
i think that's one of the reasons why
it's such a popular sport and so
fun besides athleticism and so there's
this constant trade-off between
do you want to stop the other team from
running back at you and getting an easy
basket in transition or do you want to
try and
get an extra rebound it turns out that
problem is
really complicated and really can only
be done
with overhead cameras because it's that
you can't look at it in the macro you
have to look at the marginal decisions
of
sending one more guy versus sending
another guy back
soccer is currently dealing with this
issue as well which is
which is um you know one of my bugaboos
is they pass back to the goalie a super
high risk move
for a fairly low upside but you can't
like you can't use
big data like oh let's just count how
many times you kick it backwards and see
if that team wins or not
um the analogy i use there is
if you took the best basketball team in
the world let's take golden state during
their six year run of being the best
team in the world
and every game steph curry after he got
the
tip threw it out of bounds that was his
first play of every game
well it would be this like it's amazing
that would correlate 100
with winning because every game they do
it they throw it straight out of bounds
and they win every single game and so
peop
teams should clearly follow this it
works like it happens all the time so
obviously i make a very similar very
simple correlation causation argument
but it happens all the time people say
oh the best teams don't offense a
rebound well
that that doesn't work but they'll say
the best premier league teams pass back
to the goalie well it tells you
nothing it tells you absolutely nothing
and so until you get this better data
that's over at data
in soccer and in basketball you can't
really make these decisions
and uh do you go beyond the data of the
players on the floor like
is this are you an organization that
keeps track of the players sleep
patterns and diet and does all that
uh contribute to the data set yeah
absolutely so it's been a you know the
where every team's trying to find an
edge wherever they can
sleep turns out to be this tremendous
edge but it's also a tremendous one to
gain
a hard one to gain a consistent
advantage you know i think
when you go down levels and you have
more you know you're at a college or at
a high school and you have more control
but these are professionals these are
adult
adults playing the game we definitely
work with them when they want to be
you know when they want to wear a sleep
monitor and things like that we do it
but
but we also don't like in fact the cba
not the cba but the players union
you know basically makes has rules on
how much you can instrument players both
on the court and off
and so you do your best to get them to
understand the advantage of sleep by
showing them the data which is
actually overwhelming uh but it's
it's not something that we can uh force
them into a pod in the wall
once the day is over unfortunately sadly
no they still have they still human
rights even though
they're nba players um i mean maybe the
last question on the sort of
very data focused thing is what is the
actual
sort of organizational way that it
happens when you have a team of people
sitting in front of computers uh
debating about what to collect how to
analyze it like
related to the bigger big data questions
this is a question that every field has
these days
yeah i mean i think so i can just tell
you how it is
there could be a more optimal way to do
it um but i can just say how
we do it in most teams so obviously
things start with the owner
generally there's my role gm and then
there's the coach role
and i think the best ones that i know
doc
does this and i know i do this you have
like really capable people below you
and you try to put them in an
environment where they're very
comfortable
disagreeing with you and they're very
comfortable they've
they basically have a lot of experience
and
you're then you're like the the gate
function on a multi-model where you're
you're basically saying okay i'm going
to wait i'm going to weight the
opinions of people who have a history of
being correct who line up with the data
things like that and
and and so that's the mod this is
basically a coach
down to multiple key assistants this is
true in most even other sports nfl
especially
and then obviously you know their their
role is to get the
the optimal performance out of players
and then my role is to have
you know scouts and data and programmers
make decisions on draft trade and free
agency to
get the best possible players for doc
and his career to optimize
that that's that's that's at least how
how we structure things and
uh has been successful but for sure i'm
always open to new models
should we do a uh should we do a
peer review process and and have tenure
for sure yeah i mean uh like like you
said it's it takes like
takes 25 or 30 years uh to catch up to
something obvious it's and and you said
uh analogizing to physics which was very
very interesting like where the
breakthroughs are presumably there are
just as many or
nearly as many breakthroughs yet to be
made we just haven't thought of them
right and
you must live in fear i know probably
many physicists live in fear like
they're so close to finding what the
breakthrough is and then someone else
comes up with it you're like ah yeah i
should have thought of that
yeah we don't have a timing element like
if you're a fast follower like microsoft
if you're the microsoft of nba teams
you're probably okay
if you see a team doing it they have to
put it on the floor right and then you
can aggressively
follow where you can get behind our
development systems
of you know talent identification and
helping them in the minor leagues for
example
so there is where you can develop a
sort of a bigger longitudinal advantage
but yeah we we thankfully don't have the
physics thing where you could be working
on for matt's
you know last theorem and then some guy
at princeton
you know comes up with the proof only
four people understand
all of a sudden you're you know your doa
everyone lives in fear of being scooped
in
uh in science and academia but um
so do you go so far as to use artificial
intelligence machine learning kinds of
things like do you ask the computer
look for patterns that my pitiful human
brain is not up to finding
yeah so the two big areas where you see
that
one one is with the overhead camera data
they do
automated recognition of like pick and
rolls and different
isolations and different kind of actions
that you have on the floor
and the other one would be in draft
models um
so those would be the two areas where
you see i mean to me i i grew up in the
predictive modeling world that was my uh
my other area of study at northwestern
and then since
and so if you do the um if you do the
other
basically it's all part of predictive
mode i was very lucky to take a class
with jeff hinton and michael jordan in
the 90s
which to this day i'm like i wish i had
saved the binder from it it was like a
10-day
uh 10-day course and that the other
michael jordan it's not
like the one you probably the one we
know yeah yeah okay so
i don't i don't i don't know totally
your fields of study but yeah he's he's
famous within the
predictive modeling uh on the graphical
model side and then
uh jeff hinton obviously uh on the
neural network side and
i still remember this day like they
would like come
in and say and and michael was basically
crushing
jeff hinton and saying like your your
neural nets are just special versions of
regression and useless
and and jeff was like i just need more
processing power and he was right jeff
i think jeff was more right than michael
actually so
um but yeah i don't even i just got off
a whole tangent
on on that but no actually i mean it's
fascinating because i i'm actually
interested
right these days for various reasons and
learning about that stuff
myself this whole the predicting
predictive modeling idea as far as i can
tell is
here's a giant bucket of data maybe a
time stream or a series of many
what's going to happen next right what's
the most efficient way of saying what's
going to happen next
a very tricky and intellectually
fascinating problem as it turns out
yeah i so i worked at a company called
mitre with the nsa and
cia and it was uh very near to the
oklahoma city bombing and one of the
projects i got when i was there
was predicting the next you know
domestic
terrorist act and using
like you know purchases of fertilizer
and you know messages on message boards
at the time there weren't there was no
twitter and stuff like that how do you
how do you predict uh that that's coming
and it turns out to be an incredibly
hard problem and anyone who's in
predictive modeling will know this
it's called the sunspot problem so if
you try to build a model
to predict something rare unless you
accurately tune it your model will get
really good at predicting nothing's
going to happen
it'll it'll be like right i'm pretty
sure
99.999 nothing is about to happen
and yeah and that but that's not the
point you have to tune the reward
function
on these predictive modeling problems
you have to tune it
uh such that it's developing the output
you want
draft picks are like this where you're
generally in the draft looking for more
upside so if you don't tune your models
to look for players who have a lot of
upside
you'll get you'll get unfortunately
you'll get something that's good at
predicting just a you know
slightly above replacement player
we all know time is precious and it's
not meant to be used
doing your expenses expensify
is an easy to use app that makes it easy
for you to get paid back
expensify is the most widely used
expense management platform in the world
with over 10 million users and it's made
for you the users not for finance office
administrators
expensify makes it easy to manage your
expenses your bills
invoices travel if you have any business
or corporate card spending it's all in
one place so you can focus your time
elsewhere get rid of all the paper don't
worry about losing your
receipts just take a picture and as soon
as you get it it's in your expensify
system
better yet link your credit card and
they will auto match the receipt to the
expense and submit the report for you
automatically
if you have to travel for work these
days there are lots of supported
features for the modern day traveler
such as automatic international currency
conversion
concierge for your travel needs and
mileage tracking
so visit expensify.com mindscape to get
started with a free trial
that's expensify.com mindscape
right and you're really looking for
because the nba is a game where there's
only five
players on the floor at any one time for
your team the
having the one best player is an
enormous advantage like i think a much
bigger advantage than in baseball
football anything like that
it's the largest advantage of any team
sport by a good margin
even more than quarterback and football
that's the closest that
is out there but i haven't studied for
sure but
the best analogy i give to that is in
baseball if you take the greatest
hitter of all time which was probably
barry bonds at his peak
um and he goes up to the plate to hit
uh and then he hits a home run or
whatever and he comes back
and then he has to wait eight more times
in the nba
the barry bonds the joel embiid after he
goes up and hits a whole run can be like
i'm still i'm still the best i will i
will now go up
to the plate again yeah and it's
actually worse than that for some
players so take a
take a player like ben simmons for
example
um who's on the perimeter a lot of teams
now switch
the ball screens now i'm getting two
inside basketball battles no please
you can basically you know someone
you're five are being guarded by another
five
pretty much all game in different scheme
zone and man but
mostly man in the nba and so someone's
guarding
ben simmons let's say it's a good
defender um
and what will happen is people switch a
ball screen like a
pick and roll and they can now almost
choose who to guard them so barry bonds
in basketball can not only
choose to go up every time but select
the pitcher on the other team he wants
to go against
and so like you can imagine the edge
that creates and we do it not
30 40 times a game getting up to play we
do it a hundred times
so there's a back and forth all game so
your best players
drive 90 of your value in
and but on the other side of that i mean
maybe it's a tiny correction but i
remember reading a study where
uh you there is a bit of game theory and
mixed strategy involved here right
because if
even if joel embiid is the most likely
person to score on your team
if if the other team knew you were going
to to him literally a hundred percent of
the time
they could scheme against that very very
effectively so you have to mix it up and
you have to
target your less good uh shooters some
of the time right
absolutely there's definitely game
theory and that's what makes basketball
fun
i would say though it's a little
overblown the game theory
so i call it the luis scholar right hand
problem so
anyone who's a big basketball fan luis
scola was a
big time player international and a very
good player in the nba
and he i mean he may as well have been
jim abbott and had one hand like one arm
he was he was that amazing with his
right hand
and no matter how many times he faked
with his left he'd never
shot with his left he'd come back to his
right and i'm telling you it word worked
99 of the time
so it's similar it's similar in
basketball people like okay yeah if you
know you're going to joel
every time then that's that's too easy
to stop where you know you're gonna
shoot a rim shutter three that's two
easy to stop
you it turns out when you dig in and
even adjust for all that
there's not as much game theory there as
you'd like i wish there was more game
theory actually more fun
yeah but joel has actually made a huge
step forward this year
teams are having to double him he's
having his best year
in the paint by a good margin and you're
right he has to be able to read and make
the right passes and he's he's doing
that
so yeah no it's been fun to watch you
know uh
jennifer my wife will uh testify that
i've converted her into not just a
basketball player a fan but
a 76ers fan so that we were able with
league pass
to watch a lot more games than we used
to yeah she seems like a tough
one to convert oh yeah she's very happy
to let me know when she is not
interested
in uh what we're doing but uh and now we
go to see the sixers every time they're
they play the clippers here in l.a so
that's all so funny we just announced
we're getting fans
back in philly maybe la i'll take the
little one we're
15 fans so yeah well la is especially
bad it's it's not a great place but
hopefully
hopefully we'll get vaccinated very very
soon um
speaking of human beings and biases and
decisions that they're making
know you you talked about the fact that
uh players are human beings it's
absolutely true
so are general managers and coaches and
scouts and so forth and you know one of
the interesting things i've heard you
remark about in the past
is how easy easily it is that we are
fooled as human beings and in particular
the thing that struck me is the
uselessness of interviewing
uh potential draft picks ahead of time
so yeah so i think just if you just take
a step back
from even uh the nba
i think interviews in general have been
proven to be really poor
relative to track record one of the nice
things we have is we do have
track cooker we have them in i would
argue a different sport college
basketball
it seems similar but i think it's
probably
enough different that it makes it
challenging and hard to
uh to do and so i i would say draft
interviews
are very very similar
we do our best to follow all the rules
to try to make them useful
but at least over the time i was in
houston you could prove that
uh our marginal uh ability to improve
our prediction
based on interviews was near zero and it
probably was
it probably was zero but i'm saying near
zero just to be safe
and make myself not feel as bad about
all the hours i spent
i always felt like i had to do it
because you know what if
what if the guy can't talk you know like
it's just like there's just stuff that
the other thing that comes up in draft
interviews is it is a team
and so you know getting along with other
humans is important so if you can get
any sense of that but even that's hard
and
my my general sense of why interviews
are tough is we're generally
interviewing 19
20 21 year olds and if you think back to
yourself at 19 20 21
you probably didn't have much figured
out so if we don't have if they don't
have it figured out how are we
supposed to guess what they're going to
want to do and
i would say for sure the players change
over time mature
become better leaders you know have a
have a complete change in approach and
personality that makes a big difference
so it's very very hard to predict you
know and i think i
i read you mentioning that uh you were
influenced by these ideas from conneman
and tversky
about how we human beings so not just on
the player's side
trying to sell themselves but on the
interviewer's side
we're very susceptible to signals that
might not be relevant there's a lot of
noise because we're
we're programmed to pick out the wrong
things we have all these biases
well i think it's a lot like a lot of
things people want
um a skill in one area to map to another
area
you know the people want to think that
being great at chess means you're good
at other things and i think that's been
pretty well proven to not be true
and if you put a lot of weight in
interviews
the my sense is the research is pretty
overwhelming now that
what you'll get are people who are good
at interviews which turns out to be not
not very relevant necessarily to what
whatever goal you're trying to achieve
they're good at like social cues they're
good at mirroring they're good at
they're good at like you know you know
you know saying things that are you know
familiar like even before we started the
call i was like oh
you know i grew up like this that's
similar to you i mean that's just like a
horrible
human being that people who are good at
it do it and some of them don't even
know they're good at it they're just
like it's intuitive they're good at
being around people and that can be
helpful that just knowing that can be a
data point though
i mean it makes me ask have do you think
that
trying to become the best general
manager you can possibly become
has made you a better human being or has
made you better at just
social uh interaction with the world and
analyzing things
i hope i'm a better human being i don't
know i try to
i mean you know it's just it's a
sort of a sport that we're not
vaccinating people
or saving lives i mean i guess we're
providing entertainment but
yeah um i i do think most people get
better
you know working with people over time
and i'm sure that's you know that's
that's been myself as well so i mean the
example i always use is that you would
think that
physicists who studied the universe
would eventually grow more humble over
time but empirically i don't see that
actually happening so
so yeah maybe what you expected you get
what i've been shocked by
physicists and you know that's way
better than me maybe you'll disagree
is they're just they're so
susceptible to the same biases
of um what's the right one
you know that their their theories
almost become like religion to them
yeah and so even though they've been
trained to be able to falsify their own
work right you're literally trained to
do that
they're really bad about it like they
it becomes part of their their
identification of themselves
versus a thing that's separate from them
that they should be willing to read
they should be well like if you were in
theory if
physicists were ai physicists just
machines
and they worked all their lives on
string theory
and then someone comes along and
invalidates it they should be able to be
like oh great we have this new thing
it's better i'm going to toss that out
and move to the new thing
and there are people who can do that so
i think some of the very unique
you know physicists in history could do
that
but i would say most of them are human
and have the same
problems that anyone else has no very
very much so 100
and it reminds me i just did a podcast
with roderick graham who was a
sociologist
and mostly we were talking about you
know race and
how african-americans are treated online
and i mentioned that it's a hot button
issue and you know he said oh yeah you
probably as a physicist
don't need to worry about this online
and i'm like no actually if i mentioned
the multiverse or the
interpretation of quantum mechanics
emotions grow very very heated very very
quickly people do become both attached
and anti-attached to ideas and
it is just part of being human yeah well
it's also what drives them to make great
discoveries so
i think if we didn't have that we
probably would have not
you know you almost need like obsessive
people doing things that are against
their own interests to create some of
the great discoveries
yeah no that's absolutely true but it's
actually there's an interesting
philosophy of science question here
because i know great physicists who
will articulate the idea that it is
their job to be
their theories biggest advocates and
there are other people who think it's
their job to be their theories biggest
critics right because you know they want
they want their theory to be true and
they want to be as harsh on it and i
think that i can see both sides so i
think that uh
it's just good that we have different
people coming from different attitudes
because there's no right answer there
that makes sense i would definitely be
the biggest critic one i'm
i'm a big falsified like i'm always
looking for the next best thing i'm
almost too
ready to jump onto the next interesting
thing
like that i think people are just built
differently and i hadn't thought about
the two dichotomies but you're right
both are valuable
uh at uh at different times for sure
you know and speaking of which if we
human beings are you know bundles of
heuristic
pattern recognizers uh and that's a big
um disadvantage when we can be tricked
by
a clever interviewee does it also give
us some advantage have you have you
noticed there are things that a
good scout or a good general manager can
pick
out that are just not visible there in
the data
absolutely um yeah
we had unfortunately he just recently
passed away we had a great scout named
bj
and he he had an advantage he had a data
advantage and then he got to see
players when they were younger because
he was part of like the youth basketball
circuit a little more
so he he got to see them evolve and that
gave him
i think unique data but he also had a
unique intuition that
um certain guy like i i ended up leaning
on him
for especially players who didn't have a
big college track record
because he he just again he might have
just had better data sources than me
yeah but he also had an intuitive feel i
couldn't prove that to you though but i
always felt like he did
is there is there is one of the data one
of the biases you need to worry about
overvaluing your own players i know that
you know on the online discussion boards
we all think we want to trade our uh
third string point guard for
uh an all-star from someone else's team
and they would go for it but uh
that sounds like something that you
gotta actively work to overcome i would
think
yeah it's one of the major biases uh the
endowment effect and anchoring are
probably the two
that i would say probably the three
biggest biases that really mess things
up for
endowment anchoring and uh confirmation
bias which we've been
everyone's learning about confirmation
bias because of the the uh
recent political changes in the world
like
the fact that the media is dispersed but
uh on endowment yeah to avoid endowment
which is overvaluing your own things
yeah we just force ourselves to invert
the trade it turns out to be really easy
if you invert the trade and pretend
you're holding the other thing
sometimes it's actually amazing you
realize that you wouldn't
while you're agonizing whether you do a
trade you realize if you're on the other
side you wouldn't even like
put this trade as one of the possible
trades like it's
it's not ridiculous that you're even
thinking about it it turns out to happen
all the time that
and it you do have to fight it you have
to you have to fight it
a lot i mean can you maybe give us a
little insight into the anatomy
of the negotiations for a trade is it
is it something where you're just always
talking about possibilities with all the
other teams or do you come with a
specific thing
and try to target something and hope it
works how does that go
it depends on the time period so
generally like there's
a lot of constant conversation all the
time
and then it generally sort of bubbles up
into
more as you get closer to these key
dates
and just like with most negotiations
most of them don't happen until
until there's a deadline it's like
everything in life until you have a
deadline yes they're bad
about getting things done so uh but in
negotiations there's actually a real
reason why they run to the deadline
you know which people could go read all
that research but
um and so as you get closer goes to the
deadline things get more specific
things get more transactional whereas
prior to the deadline it's more
conversations concepts
um looking for high-level fits and it's
sort of it's like a it's almost like a
sales funnel
honestly if you're into if you're into
that area of
research so yeah you have to have a lot
of things in the funnel
or you're gonna end up with not much at
the end and uh
and so uh teams of different styles some
teams
go for home run deals like where you
just
are hoping you catch a team valuing
asset very differently from you
uh and and so you don't say much
and and but it lowers your liquidity you
lower your chance of making a deal
whereas
i tend to be like i would rather
be more open um be more
open with information and more open to
try and get things done uh
because it allows you to work on the
margin so i'll miss
like home run deals uh more often but
also
hopefully get more done that um you know
help you
do the last piece to a title team for
example
i did try to time this interview so it
would not be too close to the trade
deadline i would i would never forgive
myself if you know you were doing a
podcast when you
when you could have been swinging a
massive yeah i don't think
uh spike and michael would uh forgive
you if
uh they would if you distracted me
during that at least another
four weeks it's the 25th yeah i think we
have three weeks three weeks in a couple
days
we have time and uh but but you
mentioned you know uh
there's the human side to being a gm
also knowing that your players are
players and there must be some people
who you just like and want to have on
your team and
you might have a valuation of them and
maybe that
maybe that evaporates and becomes a
little bit less important when you're
close to the deadline but you know
uh and also you want the people on your
team to like each other
right and to play well together and it
seems to me the sixers are having a good
time this year and i think that's a big
part of their success
yeah doc rivers done an amazing job i
think
one thing you have to recognize if
you're in my job is to
like you don't want people who are just
like you right you want people are
different
doc and i come from very different
backgrounds player versus not
um you know coach versus but you know
i've come to
i really i've worked with him before in
boston i really appreciate he does such
a good job
with you know getting everyone in the
same
canoe and rowing all together and
that feeling of attack like we all know
we're having to win the title but there
are different ways to attack it
and he does uh he does a fantastic job
with that
and um you know so
it's important like i'm good at certain
things doc's gonna certain things
ellen brand who does a tremendous job
with us he's
so you wanna have you wanna know where
your strengths and weaknesses are and
sort of
make sure they're complimented i think
we have a nice nice fit with that
and now i feel like i didn't answer your
question like i just went off
well let me just let me just uh say it
in a different way do you ever think
there would be a time where there was a
deal you had in front of you
where it was a close call it wasn't like
a home run and you would say
you know what i'm not going to make that
deal because i like this guy this is my
guy he's on my team let's see if we can
win with him
yeah that happens all the time so i
think when a team is rebuilding
which which i've luckily not had to do
since
since like 05 um
then then like you shouldn't really
factor that in much because
you're you're trying to optimize your
ability to
to win in multiple years from now yeah
but when you have a team like ours which
has great chemistry and i've been really
happy
you know if you if you see the quotes
from our players and it's real i'm there
every day
um you you definitely have to be careful
with that because you
like it's similar to like if you add
you know again i don't know physics
department but if you had like a bad
employee it's almost like five times
worse
yeah than adding than adding a good one
now a superstar can help but
um so so with these final pieces
it's a huge factor you need to make sure
you're not
uh or or if you add something and it's
not working you have to be able to get
out of it
like in some way like you have to have
an exit plan
well you mentioned rebuilding obviously
this is a
very touchy on both sides issue in
philadelphia where
uh under one of your predecessors sam
hinke who i was a huge fan of myself and
he worked with you in the past uh you
know they
there were a couple of years where they
didn't maximize the number of games they
were trying to win they were trying to
maximize building assets for the future
and tanking as it's called and
there are people who just you know
reject this philosophically like you
should always try to win the most games
this year do you have
feelings about this one way or the other
yeah no one should that shouldn't be
kind of like what
what sam did was exactly right and it's
why we have joel and ben now
and uh i i think it's you know the only
the only arguments that landed
against it were like ones that
philadelphia shouldn't worry about which
is
there are arguments that you know
there's some
minimum efficient quality of team you
need to present
so that you're being a good partner with
your other 29 owners
um but i mean in terms of the micro of
philadelphia what
what was done was exactly right and it's
the reason why
you know there's a lot of winning
happening right now right one of the big
reasons
yeah no i i i thought that's what you'd
say i totally agree with it uh
myself so i know i don't want to keep
you too long but i have a couple of
sort of uh you know uh wrapping up the
podcast questions here
if you were the boss of basketball if
you were uh the commissioner of the
league rather than the general manager
of the 76ers
would you tinker with the rules of the
game do you think that you can make
basketball a better game somehow
absolutely yeah so there's a whole bunch
i would do the elam ending
i would do which is like people probably
have to google that it probably will
you can accept basically it's actually
easy to say ela mending turns the end of
a basketball game into a pickup game
where you're just playing
to a score versus playing to a clock and
it turns out playing to a clock creates
all these weird skews in every sport
so that's the sports that add like
baseball or tennis
not to a clock or pure or better games
at the end
and so the elam ending switches switches
the end of it
i would have one free throw for
everything like there's no reason to
have to shoot two three free throws you
just do one free throw for every point
that you're going to get when you go i
would only allow
timeouts if the ball's already dead i
don't want to stop
i don't want to stop play um
if it's if it's live like people love
the back and forth in the live but you
don't want to stop that with timeouts
you know those are the and that i would
get to more radical things those are
just off the
off the top of my head uh some easy uh
some easy ones that i would i would
implement i mean the nba it's famous
among non-fans for the last two minutes
of the game take
20 minutes to play right that's
something that should be fixable somehow
our last a minute
17 in our trial game recently took 19
minutes
it was absolutely we're up 17 and they
cut it to seven which was
great for them but like i yeah the elam
ending would would fix that
and so it's just something we need to i
would get rid of jump balls and have
possession arrows
i mean there's just there's actually a
lot of easy stuff that would help
to help the game be more i would
definitely reduce
replay that that's torture for me like
you just have to even after replay
you're still getting things wrong
so i think everyone this should just be
a disclaimer for an nba game look we're
gonna do our best there's gonna be a few
things that are reviewed but we're
we're gonna miss things and that's okay
and sorry
and now watch your games it'll be more
fun would you also have changes to the
draft system to the lottery etc to the
we have a system now where
if you do badly you're rewarded by
getting a high draft pick and people
want to change that
that one turns out to be really tricky i
actually think the commissioners balance
that pretty well
now uh he's flat he's made it he's
flattened the odds at the top
and i in theory like if you grabbed an
economist they would say things like get
rid of the draft
they do like mike zaran a boss guy and
have a wheel where they're all
predetermined
the reality is it's pretty well balanced
now because at the end of the day we're
an entertainment business and you need
to be able to sell
tickets so the teams that are bad you
need to have
something sellable for them and the
draft is a really good way to do that
right
and gives them a lot of hope for the
future and i think i think it's pretty
well balanced
now in a system that's not
very easy to um to fix
the one thing i would do is i'd probably
do one of these hybrid systems where
instead of a draft order you would get
um
you would get like basically fake fake
coins you'd get like
chamberlain's you know like you call
them chamberlain coins like you're like
some sort of crypto bitcoin and like
whoever is the worst team will get the
most but then they could allocate
their bidding on what pick they want uh
i see okay right because if you're
rebuilding you might
instead of having to trade back from one
like
philadelphia did to get two swings at it
which actually conceptually was a
reasonable trade
obviously some of it didn't turn out but
but conceptually it was a reasonable
trade for both teams
for philly to um to trade up
and boston to trade back and and
you could be able to do that by get
instead of forcing people into their
slot
giving them more things to bid against a
class so there are things you could do
but you definitely want to give bad
teams an advantage in the draft just so
you have something to sell
if this is a very very broad
philosophical question but
uh once again given that the audience
here is eclectic what is your sales
pitch for
sports being good what do you what do
you think is the value of
sports like it's so artificial right but
it's also so compelling at the same time
well it depends on what you have as your
primary goal of life i mean i think the
greeks had it pretty well the happiness
is maybe the goal for each individual
and and clearly like entertainment is
part of that
so yeah i think it's uh i think it's a
pretty straightforward mapping to a
useful goal
and that it makes i think happiness is a
is a good goal we should have the gross
happiness broad
product like people have said if we can
measure it which we can't but
well i don't know i mean most teams do
not win the nba championship is is
sports and that happiness increase or
it's not competitive oh right because
yeah
i definitely think it's a net happiness
increase so otherwise
i know people are very irrational but
they'd have to be shockingly irrational
for the nba to be you know a you know 10
billion-ish
dollar business and uh if half the
people were miserable all the time yeah
i think people like rooting for a team
they like rooting for players they like
rooting for a process they like
rooting for you know doc rivers they
like rooting they like
being part of something a community and
i think it provides that
all right the last question is is it
true that you have skeptical thoughts
about dark matter
in the universe yeah i was gonna i was
gonna ask you this so i guess it's
trending i'm so annoyed i feel like you
know i feel like
everyone's discovering nine inch nails
now and i listen to their
albums so i've been saying so there's a
there's an analyst greg
pim who was a theoretical physicist who
worked for us in houston
and this was like i don't know 10 years
ago he works for the clippers now
and you know i was like just telling him
no there's no way
dark matter is real you just look at the
history of
of how knowledge is developed and
anytime
we're plugging the big blank with
something
that you can't observe it never turns
out to be true
and it's always that our theories are
off or measurements are off or
something's off
and so i had it like very likely that
dark matter doesn't exist and i guess
that's trendy now i've heard i have no
what is the latest on that i'm curious
you would know
yeah no sorry this is uh the one part of
our conversation i gotta dramatically
disagree here so i don't think it's
trending there's a whole bunch of people
who
think about it i mean as we've said you
know we think about all sorts of things
right you can't get too emotionally
attached
um and i've thought about it i thought
about getting rid of dark matter but
it doesn't work you know i mean i i
absolutely buy the argument you just
make if you had
a hole and you filled it with some
unknown thing but the thing about dark
matter is
we have a dozen holes and this one thing
fills them all whether it's
the rotation curves of galaxies or the
dynamics of clusters or the cosmic
microwave background or the growth of
structure
one very very simple model fits all of
it so i'm still very very bullish on
dark matter
myself is the analogy then more because
i i mean
people will say with dark matter it's
like aether in the late 1800s or
whatever but
what you're arguing is that it's closer
to quantum mechanics
where we have something that seems to
fit every observable thing
even though we don't still totally
understand how quantum mechanics work
right i'm right about that we're still
like puzzled by all that [ __ ]
you're definitely right about that i
wrote a book about it but i'm agreeing
with you yes
there you go um and so i mean
okay but so that's your art that that
makes
that makes sense but i still feel like
there's some
[Music]
you know theory that could overlay and
explain
all that too potentially right but
you're saying the odds are getting low
that
that maybe that's the case i think i
think actually it's a it's a very
interesting history of science question
because you know in the 80s or 90s
uh your point of view that dark matter
is a temporary holding place for a more
deep understanding would have been 100
respectable and again like i definitely
thought about it myself but i don't
think that we as cosmologists have quite
conveyed to the public the extent to
which that
changed when we really started observing
the cosmic microwave background
in detail you could make predictions if
dark matter exists that
cmb will look a certain way if it
doesn't exist it will look another way
and it came
bang in on what was predicted by dark
matter in a way that
it's almost impossible i never want to
say impossible but it's
almost impossible to reproduce that
success
in the model where you just change
gravity without dark
you're saying something important that i
didn't know i didn't know about the cmb
stuff yeah that a prediction was made
prior to knowing the result and then it
turned out to fit
the theory and so that's important i
mean that's
that's what happened with quantum
mechanics like a long time if i'm right
you tell me
right where where the theory kept
predicting things that kept
being true over and over and even though
we didn't quite know the full mechanism
although we know it
much better now to your point um that
that it's
so what is the best candidate is that
like these like these huge
like uh remnants of the big bang like
what is the best
candidate at this point well that's i
think the the
totally fair worry is that for a long
time we had a favorite candidate the
weekly interacting mess of particles
right we
have the weak interaction of particle
physics the wimps right we have the weak
interactions of particle physics
it's very easy to invent a new particle
that is not electrically charged but
does feel the weak interactions
it very naturally would have the right
abundance in the universe to be the dark
matter
but we could have found it by now and we
it's like
still the chances that we would have had
it by now or maybe like 60
it's not like 99.9 but we had a good
chance of finding it by now and we
haven't
so at some point your credences has got
have got to go lower and
to me that doesn't decrease my credence
and dark matter that much but the
uh more esoteric candidates like axions
are a famous uh candidate they're very
very light particle
lighter than a neutrino basically but
that could sort of
be left over from the big bang in
interesting ways and so
if it's not a wimp if the dark matter
exists but it's not a wimp
then there's a dozens of other
candidates
does it interact with anything does it
lens does it gravitationally lens
stuff what is it like what is absolutely
yeah i mean that's the one thing we know
about dark matter that it has a
gravitational effect that's why we know
it's there that's why we were led to
believe
it's there and in fact these days we
literally
map it you know we know where it is
through gravitational lensing mostly so
you get these gorgeous
images you know three-dimensional
reconstructions of the dark matter
density
even though we have never detected the
particle that it actually is
still feels like it's going to be
something totally we don't i'm just
like it feels like
yeah my gut tilts up but of course i
just have my gut and your gut's better
than mine it's more
more more experienced one of the reasons
why i
i feel justified in being so confident
about this
is that i would love it if i were wrong
like noah would be happier than i would
be
if there was something interesting going
on with gravity
that is tricked us we don't even totally
understand gravity right so that's
another thing right
we don't totally understand anything we
we actually understand gravity
on scales of the solar system and larger
pretty well
we're able to imagine other things i've
written papers imagining other things
but you know i think einstein
more or less nailed that on
astrophysical scales gravity is is
pretty well under control
gotcha i do we i think it's just the
simulation people have effing with us
they're just like they're just like oh
they're looking again they're they're
trying to see if they can find the dark
matter we'll
we'll put it in there that is you know i
literally
when we were looking for the higgs boson
back before the large hadron collider
turned on
i i literally had a theory that uh
every place we looked like there was a
probability of seeing the higgs boson
with different masses
and whenever we looked and didn't find
it it just moved up
and you can invent physics theories
along those lines but i think for the
dark matter it's just we haven't been
clever enough yet we don't have enough
direct evidence
why didn't we stop the collider in texas
that would have been awesome
like i'm so annoyed that that yeah
we uh we it would have been not only
earlier but it was a
more powerful accelerator than the large
headers are we getting that or we still
it feels like it set science back like
25 years
now the united states has entirely
abandoned
even the attempt to build uh world-class
particle accelerators
so um right now the debate on what the
next one will be
is between china and europe i remember
biden making this a big part of his
platform i'm surprised
the physics community doesn't know about
it yeah no it's uh it's it's
they're expensive you know and i and i
get that but we build them once every 20
or 30 years i think
it's worth the expense myself oh it's
easily worth the expense yeah yeah
all my friends are like now tell me it's
stupid to go to mars and i'm like yeah
it is but like why wouldn't we like
we'll learn we'll learn something right
it'll be interesting
it's part of a portfolio you got to do
some crazy things you got to do some
ambitious things because you don't
know uh you know i had martin reece
famous theoretical astrophysicist on the
podcast
and he points out that people were
worried when we turned on the large
hadron collider would it destroy the
earth
and he was literally even though he's
british he was called before congress to
testify
and he said you know as a careful
scientist
i can't promise you it won't destroy the
earth but
i can't promise you it won't be free
energy and cure all the diseases we have
either like we
those are fringe things that we can't
care about we can't control those like
let's look at the likely thing in this
particular case well politics
immediately do really bad with orders of
magnitude
so yeah they're like yes it's possible
that this could happen but it's also
possible that
a plane can crash into my building right
now
and they can't distinguish that fear
from one that's ten percent like we just
do really bad between ten percent one
percent point one percent we're really
terrible at that so
yeah there is some some bias i i think
it i don't know if it has a name or not
but the only percentages that people
believe in are 0
50 and 100 as far as i know all right i
think
i think nate silver is a good friend has
talked about that
quite a bit um but well here's the
bottom line i
i say we start off talking about
championship odds in vegas
what is the current betting odds on them
finding dark matter in the next five
years there must be somewhere you can
wager on this
yeah no i'm i'm sure there are and if
you would ask me five years ago
i would have said it's over 50 chance
that we would have found it by now
that's why
uh that that does raise some skepticism
i think
but so if it's not a weekly interacting
massive particle
then there's still wonderful evidence
that dark matter exists but none of the
other candidates are
as easily searchable so we might be
stuck for the rest of our lifetimes
right with uh thinking
i'm glad you guys didn't call it the
[ __ ] the ground there's a whole bunch of
whole whole bunch of bad puns in physics
so and on that note daryl mori thanks so
much for being on the mindscape podcast
this was great
thanks so much john appreciate it
[Music]
you